every entrepreneur
must be optimistic in some way otherwise
it just nobody really can survive
[Music]
david thank you for joining me and
giving me your time
thank you michael nice to meet you how
you doing so you're talking to me from
dallas
from austin actually right yes correct
how are you and
and you just moved here you moved there
before the corona started
i i actually in between i i cut the last
uh
flight from israel uh to the united
states
the last one the last one day there's a
flight yes
wow okay well that's that's that's it's
a good thing you got the last one and
how is it over there right now is it
crazy
uh it it depends if it's
like everything is compared either we
have some friends in new york and they
are suffering really hard and compared
to oh yeah we are in pretty good
situation right now but definitely okay
so so the most important thing to note
is that i'm speaking here to an optimist
which is great
i love that and and you consider
yourself um
well versed and what it means to bring
happiness to consumers
uh that's my little dog here benny who
might who might make an appearance so
we'll just let him
set aside for a little bit before he
gets us into trouble
and then i'd love to sort of walk
through a little bit about your history
your background and how you even
why how you got excited about this topic
and you know i
i would love to touch also a little bit
on what it means to be to have a startup
you're the skill of a startup in the
travel space and marketplace
on the travel space and you know it's
pretty challenging times for these sorts
of companies now so maybe you can touch
on that a little bit at the end
so let's just get started tell me a
little bit about yourself
uh so my name is david i was born in
russia i moved
to israel when i was 12 since
2016 i work a lot with u.s companies i
actually started my career
at the company called nds i built the
various security solutions for digital
tv
my projects were directv biscay b and
some other big
corporate clients
i moved to
my own business my own startups at 2010
and since that period i had an
experience working on
different uh products from uh
financial industry advertising and etc
i was part of nfx guild
accelerator in palo alto three years ago
actually was a co-founder of
free startups bought with many different
other startups as well as fortune 500
companies uh i joined stride
a year ago a bit more than a year ago
and right now we are in pretty
interesting
and challenging time yeah
we do believe that we will
create a serious impact for
people when all this madness over and uh
definitely will will definitely want to
go to
some great safari tours or some
interesting
experience in himalaya or some amazing
tours
that they are like dreaming right now
all the time and uh
we'll help them to make it real soon
as a company yes oh wonderful
wonderful that that's amazing i actually
did i did i went
to kilimanjaro a few months ago with my
family as well as a safari
and it was one of the most extraordinary
experiences that i've ever had
tell me a little bit about yourself and
why you consider yourself
an optimist and what makes you
think about you know bringing happiness
to consumers
so i i worked a lot on b2b projects and
the different projects
uh that didn't make me feel
they they helped me to get pretty good
money on one side and i also
invested in some other south of as well
but it's it's
not something that creates uh meaning in
your life and
it doesn't provide any serious value and
you really want to
move forward to build something that
actually
you want to wake up for and move
yourself over
when i was a kid i asked my mother like
uh what does it mean being happy
and i got the following answer from her
when you wake up early in the morning
you
are happy to go to work and at the
evening you are happy to go home
this was her definition of the happiness
i try to define it myself i i i probably
still working on this and my wife always
uh joking at me like
are you talking about uh happiness you
you are still
uh struggling to define it for yourself
like but how
can you actually provide the happiness
to other so
try to first of all find it in yourself
and this kind of
tip that i actually recommend to all
other
people entrepreneurs and just people who
want to work in a great environment
first of all from your personal life
like define
what does it mean happiness for yourself
like uh
is it really something that uh
matters to you at all like can you take
it from there
just uh an example on myself like what
does it mean
happen being happy for myself it's uh
spending time with
people i like and people i love my
family for example
i do like helping other as well
uh i highly believe in solidarity and
it's a great example right now in those
crazy times that
people share some food that they bought
and uh some
mosque and helping each other it's
something that to make
huge impact and on a personal level
integrity is something that's really
important as well
those are my points my metrics
when you go to your
job for example what what matters
to you like uh what kind of people you
would like to work with
i i can give an example i personally
like working with people who are doers
who are actually can deliver something
uh i do want to be in a supporting
environment
people who help each other and don't
blame each other like this year for them
etc etc it's uh really important that
people respect each other as well it's a
critical to have
really great relationship relationships
in a company as well
and the the entrepreneurial mindset is
something that also makes me happy
and when uh we are moving the same uh
pattern to product
uh what what do you like about your
product like uh
uh right user experience right uh
you do want that the product you're
using
or making share some common values with
you so like uh
the product must be aligned with your
values
that you believe in and if it's
something that uh
you don't believe you will never use it
right right
and the on another part
when you build a product you want real
to fans
and when you make like a significant
impact
you will have those fans and they
they they have some feelings about your
product and
let's say you release something they
didn't like their response
listen we didn't like this and we didn't
like that but we really want
this back and then so so they will try
to convince you
that this type of uh product needs to be
updated or changed and and so on
the worst part for any
product is people who don't really care
about uh
it at all like uh this product is
indifferent to me like
today you are a hero that's fine we are
fighting on just a price and that's it
and tomorrow someone else will just uh
improve their supply chain and reduce
uh some pricing costs and the there is
no product at all like uh and
your company just goes away right the
those kind of things that really matter
i highly recommend for any
person who is involved in product
building product definition first of all
start from your life
move to your work definition and then
move to product and the
by this you can actually define all the
process yourself
no that makes a lot of sense and you
know so i i do i do agree
on a lot of points here and i think this
idea of resilience
and what what allows you to to keep
going and even when the going gets
trough and you know having those users
aligned with with your core values and
when your product
shares those core values then the users
are not just you know
buying your product but they're they're
all of a sudden becoming champions of it
and they feel
personally attached to it and you
actually i did a little bit of research
before and
i i think you have a pretty interesting
story of a bicycle accident right did i
see correct and
yeah and you broke both your hands and
you and you managed to
still do something interesting while
breaking both of your hands
yeah it's it's it's it's all sorry about
i i had some accident and i was
uh in in some like
crazy situation uh seven
eight years ago actually yeah and uh i i
had to
recover myself personally financially
and just everywhere
and uh it was a very challenging
situation um one person that
probably really helped me to move
over this situation was my wife and she
actually helped me
and she was extremely supportive during
this period of time
and uh you always need this person uh
some some other people that uh i
got all the inspiration from uh
more people that were around me and they
actually helped me to move forward and
it's
it's pretty important uh situation
and then you actually during that time
you you learned ruby on rails
right uh not not exactly i actually
had previously experienced with ruby on
rails
i think it was a version 1.8 at mds
that time and
i started checking what's going on on on
the market right now where where can i
go
next like what should i do i had like
very serious uh
bicycle accident i should move over i
wasn't able really to write a code at
that time
because i was
fully disabled and
i said okay i know that
ruby on rails has like a very
serious impact on many startups at that
time
right and the base camp was uh
developed during this period and some
other great startups and
i said like i i have to move with this
software this software actually helps uh
a lot of developers just to build great
stuff and i i can
move forward i started uh learning just
by doing
and uh at the same time the demand
just uh became very high and
i started helping other startups and uh
move forward from this period yeah
and so you became some you became a
consultant on ruby i i i
also did some consulting not only for
startups but i work with a company like
conduit
and some other big companies as well i
work with
gardner new york and
pricewatercooperhouse in san francisco
and uh
so i i actually had the startup
experience as well as
fortune 500 as well so tell me a little
bit about about stride and
what are some of the core values that
you have over there that are
you know aligned with yours that that
bring happiness to users
first of all being a travel industry is
uh is a great thing to
deal with right it's it's something that
you
always like uh to travel unless you
prefer receiving on your coach and just
uh watch tv on netflix or whatever but
uh
most people do like uh traveling
especially in those
crazy times so i'm very aligned with
the major goal uh helping
people to find exactly where they can go
right now what what type of experience
they can get in various places around
board not not only just uh
on an extra street or just around the
view but
all over and this is something that we
are trying to
achieve by helping people to move all
around
get to know many different gems around
the world
and move forward and this probably the
most
interesting part in stride that
we are working on right now and
so what what is it like being a cto of
an upcoming startup and
all of a sudden corona breaks out
good question it's it's it's challenging
listen uh
they're always ups and downs and uh it
highly depends if you
have uh enough uh time with your cash
on a personal level as well as on the
company level yeah
you sometimes you you have to make
immediate decisions like
some people you have to lay out or fire
or just
post some projects specifically
concentrate on cash
it's probably the most important one
measure everything you are doing many
times a day
starting from planning uh is
the thing that you are working right now
really matters to you or
and to your customers will this
something that
will make a change in upcoming months
how people actually gonna spend their
time
on travel after the coronavirus
pass will they actually travel abroad
or they try to stay around so there are
there are a lot of questions that we are
trying to answer right now
and i assume that nobody actually knows
the tournament so
right but uh we will see it's it's
uh it's it's a interesting time it's an
interesting uh
challenge and really we're here to
make it uh work and i i i'm optimistic
by by my nature because being a
pessimistic doesn't uh provide any value
and uh
you need some uh like personal balance
in your life just to move forward and uh
it's something that uh pretty important
how important
is it do you think to be an optimist as
in a leadership team whether it's a
startup or a big company you know rather
than being
the pessimist or the realist that is
always you know trying to give the
the bad side to things because there are
balancing
personalities that i would find useful
also in our leadership team
correct so so sometimes you see
being too optimistic is not always good
like you're trying to
oversell yourself too much you're trying
to
bring too much promises without actually
providing any value and it's not good at
some point it just
creates a negative impact
uh on the other side uh you always
should be
more optimistic than realist or
pessimist i i don't know
and uh be prepared because uh
the future is bright and we wanna uh go
to something uh
happy and uh dealing with something that
doesn't
really matter at all it's uh it doesn't
provide any motivation
neither do you nor to your team and it
doesn't uh provide like any any serious
value and i think
every entrepreneur uh
must be optimistic in some way otherwise
it just uh nobody really can survive it
and uh when i'm
a startup founder i
wake up every morning i decide this is
the
experiment that i gonna do today at the
end of the day this experiment will fail
and the next morning i have to wake up
with the same attitude
that i'll gonna make exponent number two
and uh this exponent may fail as well
but uh this uh startup life and it's uh
it's crucial uh for you to survive this
uh
kind of trial and error uh
routine and being optimistic is a
must-have
and and how do you then you know um
delegate that happiness and optimism to
the people that work under you as a cto
because you know
you're not necessarily the one who is
writing all the code and
a lot of the times you have to also put
on this product hat and you have to
bring a lot of that down you know top
down for the team so how
what are some of the ways that you do
that great question so
you really need to split uh
your thoughts uh your stories your into
like small
chunks small tasks and uh this
actually helps to deliver faster and
make frequent delivers actually helps
the team
move forward and right this this type of
uh
development mindset actually helps a lot
because
let's say if you decide on building a
product
with a huge amount of features and the
big list of requirements and so on
no nobody really can deliver it but if
you just
split it into small chunks of
requirements
and every time you build something you
deliver it you test it immediately you
get an impact
and and and so on this actually helps
people who works with you move forward
and see the real impact and every
line of code should have an impact if
the line
nobody writes code just uh like as
beautiful code it really doesn't matter
like
seriously sometimes you just have to
realize will people actually you know
enjoy having this situation it doesn't
matter if you work on
client uh right now or you are building
some back office
just uh put uh on your head
um the same person and try to do the
same
process definitely make
make you happy just using this project
it's something that i always
uh request from developers just try to
use it yourself like
will you actually use it like literally
and uh
you don't need the design you don't need
the user experience
guy and so on just be with the user
yourself
definitely definitely so we have we have
to we our 20 minutes is coming up but
i'd love to ask you the final question
and it's putting you a little bit on the
spot but what are three words that you
would best describe you as i already
know at least one of them
uh but what are the three that you would
best describe yourself as
well optimism is one of those
i like helping people is the second one
and i'm i'm i'm entrepreneur
like traveling and move forward that's
really really great
david thank you very very much thank you
great take care bye bye